I gotta tell you you got the Palm
Springs tan you got the Palm Springs
gloves I just got back from Mexico okay
it's a lot different weather here than
it is in Mexico I don't think of rain in
Palm Springs at all uh listen you're
getting the Breakthrough performance
award tonight and you're in some good
company Romney Malik mahershala Ali
Lupita nyango Brie Larson now I'm not
trying to make you nervous but they all
went on to win the Oscar how's it feel
to be in their company man it's just the
biggest honor I feel so privileged to be
here it feels amazing it's something
else uh you know I know you had said
that you know because you were so
dedicated to this role you really didn't
see your family for like three years so
standing here tonight where you're being
recognized by the Palm Springs Festival
does it feel like that was all worth it
yeah I mean
my family's so supportive they're just
amazing and it's actually special being
here because we used to the only
vacation we took when I was a kid was to
here in Palm Springs so really yeah it
kind of ties it all together are they
here with you tonight or no no sadly
they're not here they're they're in
other states right now now I know with
Cove and everything you probably get a
plus one to the Golden Globes but have
you decided who you're going to bring
yet on that big night yeah I'm gonna
bring my sister you are that's awesome
that must have been a tough decision
though it's hard but you know she's uh
my one and only sister so it'll be nice
to be with her you know obviously Elvis
was a Trailblazer uh you know and what
ways did he kind of help pave the way
for you to be here well you know he was
he was somebody who was so true to
himself yeah you know and uh and it
liberated a lot of people you know even
just audiences watching him and I know
that that was my experience playing him
was it freed me in many ways yeah you
know I'm very shy so it forced me to get
things out of me yeah you know so yeah
it's a gift they gave me
[Music]